pme obnl petits entrepreneurs
travailleurs autonomes
on répond à vos questions stéphane
leblanc bonsoir bonsoir on a
l'impression aujourd'hui avec la
bonification l'élargissement du conte
d'urgence pour les entreprises qu'on
voit touchée
dorénavant tous les petits entrepreneurs
qui ont besoin d'argent qui ont besoin
d'emprunter de l'argent
exactement lorsqu'on arrive en masse
salariale de 20 mille d'horreur qui les
nouveaux critères qui ont été établies
aujourd'hui donc on va vraiment les
toucher aussi même des travailleurs
autonomes qui ont qui se paye un thé au
gnouf en masse salariale donc va avoir
du soleil mais on va quand même assez
loin la 1 m $ de masse salariale cés
police et des petites entreprises au
départ est autonome avec un employé boys
donc masse salariale de 20 mille à un
million cinq cent mille vous allez
répondre tout de suite un délire
question un dividende est il considéré
comme étant dans la masse salariale non
canton pour le compte de l'urgence aux
prises le dividende n'est pas considérée
dans la masse salariale pour l'arménie
pour que ça dans la masse salariale pour
que ce soit vraiment un salaire qui est
payée par l'entreprise donc les
dividendes ne compte pas pauvre c est ce
qu un obnl qui n'a payé que des pigistes
en 2019 à hauteur de 50 mille a accès
aux prêts on a versé des honoraires des
pigistes qui nous ont fait des factures
nous demande fabienne donc pas réussi
des pigistes
c'est des travailleurs autonomes
indépendants donc ce ne sont pas des
salariés de nos bnr les congés parentaux
il s'appelle sa peur des masses
salariales donc ça prend du salaire que
le pays et ça c'est pas considérer un
pigiste n'est pas considérée comme ça la
vie donc c'est pas considérer les
honoraires ne sont pas du solaire pays
pour les fins du conte d'urgence de
pauvres pour les entreprises ok très
clair donc c'est important de voir les
limites ans qui a le droit véritablement
à ces prêts sans intérêt on y va avec
une autre question est ce qu'on peut
déclarer comme dépenses les frais reliés
à un bureau à domicile pendant la crise
puisqu'on doit travailler de la maison
demande richard
non mais ça c'est une très bonne
question et c'est pas clair parce que il
ya des conditions
normalement pour que notre bureau à
domicile soit un complice par des
dépenses pour le bureau à domicile
mais avec la situation actuelle c'est
pas clair si on respecte ces conditions
là on s'attend à des éclaircissements
d'absents cloche et que ces
éclaircissements devons être positifs
autant de la part des agences du canada
et de revenu québec dont on attend des
réponses sur le sujet de dali dans les
livres dans un prochain billet ok donc
il ya encore un flou là dessus on y va
avec une autre question une coiffeuse à
son compte qui gagnent moins de 1000 $
par mois et qui a gagné aussi moins de
1000 $ par mois en 2019 et l admissibles
aux nouvelles règles de la prestation
canadienne d'urgence oui donc avec les
nouvelles règles maintenant d'enfance
qu'il faut le pain sec et à suivre c'est
que pour la première demande
la station elle-même d'urgence pendant
au moins 14 jours consécutifs pour une
pour une pour la période de quatre
semaines pour les premières et indiqué
yves marcoux vont en ville donc et il
faut qu'elle ait qu'un ni moins de 1000
$ de revenus d'emploi ou de travail et
dépendent donc et l état seront content
de travailler dépendants et il a baissé
pour la deuxième période de quatre
semaines par exemple 12 avril au 9 mai
il faut pas que ça tend à faire plus que
1000 $ de travail est dépendant au cours
de cette période deux donc c'est un
mille dollars pour le mois pour le quart
semaine et de cette façon là avec une
nouvelle aile qui ont été annoncés hier
elle devrait être admissible si elle
respecte les consignes intéressant parce
qu'on était à 0 mais la semil mec no 1
la ligne le film mille dollars de
revenus ou moins c'est bien ça peut-on
comme entrepreneur c'est 6 de se verser
un salaire travailler quand même et
demandé la prestation d'urgence johan
ici ici on est dans une zone grise
parce que ya un critère qui d'enquêté
mis dans la loi pour les prestations
d'urgence de ne pas avoir quitté son
emploi de façon volontaire donc là le
repreneur qui est dans ces sociétés
ils sont vos employeurs donc est ce que
l on peut dire qu'il a quitté
volontairement son travail en se payant
pas de revenus de salah donc c'est pas
clair
donc on n'a pas de réponse pour cette
question là par contre nantes
pourrez regarder un autre qui qualifie
l'art et aux tests de baisse de revenus
de voir ce qu'il est admissible à la
subvention de ce soir est responsable
sur le salaire qui se paye et donc comme
ça aussi été récompensé de cette façon
là à la place parce que respecter aussi
l'esprit de la loi et l'esprit des
programmes
c'est important quand même
exhaustivement dans le code de la
prestation canadienne d'urgence si un
travailleur autonome exécute un travail
le 15 avril le facture de 15 me et
touche le paiement le 1er juillet
quand ce revenu est il considéré comme
comme reçu ça aussi c'est une excellente
question qui malheureusement
malheureusement la réponse est
incertaine selon notre compréhension de
la loi
l'attraction et éthiques on parle
d'exécuter un travail au cours de la
période
qualifiant par exemple il exécute son
travail dans ce cas ci le 15 avril
donc quand j'interprète la loi moi je
suis de près ça devrait considérer
considérons un revenu du 15 avril
peu importe quand s il est facturé ou
peut être pas quand est-ce les pays mais
on attend des précisions c'est des
questions qui ont été posées au
gouvernement mais on n'a pas rêvé
sciences de juger là parce que la
réponse elle n'est pas clair c'est ce
que ça pourrait être la comptabilité
d'exercice cloche pour un expert
comptable donc la facture de 15 mai la
bonne date
oui ça pourrait intéresser aussi
effectivement c'est pour ça que
l'interprétation est pas claire mais le
fait qu'on parle d' exécuter apparaît
lorsqu'on exécute paraît que c'est au
moment où on grands lacs
ouais donc c'est pour ça que ça pourrait
être également mais on attend les
précisions à ce sujet lors d'un contrôle
nous sommes un obnl nous sommes à
l'arrêt mais nous continuons de recevoir
nos subventions du gouvernement
nos employés peuvent tirer clamer la pcu
même s'ils n'ont pas perdu leur emploi
ni leur salaire est ce que ça prend un
relevé d'emploi donc pour la première
bévue de la question s'ils continuent à
gagner un salaire ne devraient pas avoir
le droit la pcu à moins que depuis hier
avec les nouvelles qu'ils gagnent moins
quinze heures par mois donc en
respectant les nouvelles donc ça ça
pourrait être ça mais sinon s'ils
gagnent plus que mènera par mois il
continue à recevoir un salaire donc et
on peut doit les prestations canadiennes
d'urgence il pour demander l'arrestation
grain d'urgence on n'a pas besoin de
présenter deux relevés d'emploi
donc c'est pas nécessaire je suis
courtiers immobiliers travailleurs
autonomes je reçois des paiements
plusieurs semaines après les
transactions comment la pcu et elle
positionnée pour moi donc en reste des
questions sans semble semblable à celle
de temps en taule
on est encore à se droguer parce qu'un
quart d'heure ben on parle de l'été
reste consécutifs de 14 jours sans
revenus puis on parle du travail exécuté
donc est ce que le fait d'avoir deux
collectivités ont dû recevoir l'hostie
colloque parce que l'enfant cette
transaction avait déjà eu lieu c'est
seulement qui reçoit plusieurs semaines
plus tard le profit de ces leçons en a
qui étaient comme qui détonne
je vous arrête on a compris je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée merci d'avoir
été avec nous nos protéines bonne soirée
notre antenne on se retrouve demain
[Musique]